your life today if you don't like the  life you're living today it's because  the way you think and if you don't like  your life you have to change the way you  think and if you don't change the way  you think your life ain't going to  change you can't blame the government  you can't blame the parents you can't  blame your boss you can't blame your ex  you can't blame nobody it's you and yes  this is a tough one but here's the good  news if you do make the changes the good  changes the changes of here of the way  you think  whatever life you're gonna live next is  ten times better than the life you live  in today but you got to be willing to  make those changes